. Hey, hey, hallo, hey, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von DPU, das Podcast U, von natürlich mir gegenüber wie immer ein wenig ungeduldig. Stefan Titzel-Wann geht's los, wann kann ich endlich anfangen zu reden und gegenüber von mir sitzt, aber eher leicht schräg, müsst ihr euch vorstellen, nicht direkt gegenüber, sondern leicht links versetzt Flutimbel. Weil ich einfach weiß, dass meine linke Kopfhälfte besser aussieht. Deswegen versuche ich alle Leute ein bisschen nach rechts zu setzen, damit sie so ein bisschen meine linke Kopfhälfte kriegen. Ist bei mir auch so. Bei mir sieht links besser aus als rechts, weil ich einen Wirbel oben habe, der den Anschein eines, was ich nicht so krass habe, einer Geheimratsecke nahelegt. Und deswegen gucke ich meistens Leute so leicht von links an. Aber sind nicht alle von links besser? Ich glaube, ich habe noch niemand gehört, meine gute Seite ist die rechte Seite. Ich glaube, es ist eigentlich immer links. Und ich glaube, so in Fotos, wenn man anschaut, so der klassische Instagram-Tipp, ich war ja mal in der Frank-Elser-Masterclass, wo ein Social-Media-Experte uns besucht hat, der uns gesagt hat, wie man auf Social-Media-Erfolg hat. Und der hat gesagt, Männer dürfen nie in die Kamera schauen, sondern immer aus dem Bild raus. Und dann habe ich mal darauf geachtet, so wenn man das weiß, dann machen das tatsächlich viele. Aber immer gucken sie nach links raus von der Betrachterseite. Also ist die linke Seite dann die Eigenschaft.
Aber führt auch so ein bisschen dann so zum Kampf wahrscheinlich, bei so einem grossen Gruppenfoto von einem Film, ich denke an Roten Teppich, großer Film, dass alle Männer erstens rausgucken, weird, und dass die alle in die gleiche Richtung gucken, auch seltsam, was dann den Anschein macht, als auf was sehr Spannendes irgendwie in der linken Bildhälfte passieren würde, was man nicht sieht. Wobei das, glaube ich, mein genereller Blick auf Partys ist. Dieses leicht halsgereckte, kenne ich hier jemandenblick.
Weg aus dem Gespräch kenne ich jemanden, wo ist Stefan Blick? Das ist immer so mein Blick auf Partys. Ja, mein Blick ist ja immer, ich bin immer gross und deswegen habe ich immer sehr viele Orkut-Blickkontakte mit anderen grossen Menschen. Wie so Bojen im Meer, wo alles unten drunter ist und man sieht sich so über Kilometer hinweg.
Man hofft so auf Wellengang, damit man die Bojen nicht immer sieht. Das heißt, Comedypreis war immer, Olivia und Jones und ich gucken uns an, haben uns aber nichts zu sagen, kennen uns auch nicht, aber irgendwann grüsst man sich schon so. Irgendwann finden sich die Blicke und dann muss man auch einen kurzen... Ja, und es war immer ein bisschen orkulär mit anderen grossen Menschen, dass man es immer so sieht, weil man über die Menschen hinweg guckt. Ist ja wie so eine Hobbit-Landschaft, so aus Köpfen, aus sich bewegenden, wellenartigen, ist wirklich wie eine Boje, so ein bisschen, auf der Tanzfläche, dann will die dann alle so auf und ab wackeln, ja, von daher awkward, ein bisschen. Ich glaube, so war das zum Beispiel auch im Mittelalter, wenn Leute Pferde hatten. Das sind so eine Menschenmenge und drei Leute haben Pferde und die sehen sich ja. Die Pferde sehen sich. Die Pferde sehen sich, die Reiter sehen sich und man ist so eine Gruppe in der Gruppe so. Raumübergreifend ist man eine Gruppe mit den Grossen. Warum hat es aufgehört, dass wir alle auf Pferden reisen, ähnlich schnell wie ein Auto in Innenstädten? Die Unfallgefahr war zu hoch und irgendwann wollten die ja noch irgendwie eine Gewerkschaft, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung haben. Ja, die Pferde. Tatsächlich haben wir einen Tweet bekommen von einem Hörer, Hörerin, der meinte, dass Pferde im Mittelalter viel kleiner waren als heutige Pferde. Und deswegen man oft auf Statuen und so die Verhältnisse falsch macht und eigentlich wären die eher so.
Eigentlich sind die Ritter immer mit den Füßen so über den Boden geschliffen, oder nicht?
Ja genau, wie so ein Roller mussten sie immer so antauchen und deswegen meint es, es ist eher auf aktuellem Pony-Niveau, waren die damalige Pferdegröße. Aber sahen nicht so süss aus wie Ponys? Ne, sahen furchteinflössend Schlachtrösser aus, aber waren einfach sehr klein und setzt auch nochmal zum Beispiel sowas wie Genghis Khan einfach nochmal ein ganz anderes Licht, weil diese Reiterhorden einfach süss, immer niedlich sind, wie so Menschen auf so kleinen Motorrädern, die so lächerlich kleine Motorräder sind. Wie so auf Esel. Ich meine, die kommen auch voran, das ist auch immer noch ein starker Angriff, wenn du Leute auf solchen kleinen Motorrädern hast, aber es ist halt einfach auch ein bisschen albern ja merkwürdig also das ist irgendwie die vergangenheit war weird oder kann man jemanden realistischen zeitreisefilm machen so einen unsagbar realistischen zeitreisefilm ich glaube der realistische zeitreisefilm wenn man reist in die vergangenheit und sagt ach ne ne hier Und stinkt's bestialisch. Es stinkt, alle sind klein, krumm, alle sind wahnsinnig dumm, krank, man lebt nur drei Tage, weil danach steht man an der Pest oder sowas.
Es ist merkwürdig, glaube ich. Niemand ist rasiert, es gibt kein Glas, vergisst man auch manchmal, dass es Glas nicht gab.
Wann kam Glas dazu?
Alle Fenster waren einfach entweder immer zu oder immer offen. Und man sagt, wollen wir kurz Fenster aufmachen? Ja, aber das war kalt. Ja, dann ist es aber kalt. Dann lass es zu, dann leben wir weiter in Dunkelheit. Ja, nervig. Ich würde irgendwas zurücklassen. Ich habe so einen TikTok gesehen von jemandem, der sagt, wenn ich ein Objekt ins Mittelalter transferieren könnte, dann das. Und das war so wie so ein Quizshow-Buzzer, so ein grüner Buzzer, wo wenn man drauf drückt, so Punjabi-MC gespielt wird. Naja. Und man denkt, ja, das ist eigentlich ideal, um das ins Mittelalter zu werfen, dass es irgendein Fünder und ... Didelidelidelidelidelidelidelidel und einfach so ein ... Was geschieht? Was geht hier vor sich? Was ist das für ein merkwürdiges Geplapper, was da rauskommt? Ein Hexengerät. Ein Hexengerät. Und einfach so völlig unerklärbar. Wie funktioniert das? Noch nie Musik gehört, nichts in der Richtung. Nee, das finde ich sehr lustig. Auch weil es ja auch in der Jetztzeit keinen denkbar klaren Zweck erfüllt. Also auch keine Lösung auf ein Problem ist oder sowas.
Eher selber ein Problem.
Eher nochmal weitere Fragen auch in der Jetztzeit aufwirft
und in der Vergangenheit ja quasi alles eher pragmatische Antworten auf Probleme waren.
Aber ich frage mich wirklich, weil, glaubst du, Pferde kommen zurück?
Weil die sind ja CO2-sparsam.
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber ist es nicht bei Kühen auch so, dass die viel dazu beitragen? Kühe sind ja ein ganz anderes Thema. Kühe sind ja nochmal ein ganz anderes Problem. Tut mir leid, ich habe meine Power verwechselt, da komme ich manchmal dazu. Ja, kann schon sein. Kann gut sein, aber dann glaube ich, würde man eher wieder in die Richtung Kleimpferd gehen. Kleines, starkes Pferd, wirklich wie so auf Fahrrad, Fahrradfahrradgrösse, oder halt so kleine Pferde mieten, wie jetzt mit den Apps, mit den kleinen Rollern hast du halt in der Stadt überall so kleine Pferde stehen, so Ponys, also wirklich teilweise nur so kniehoch, wo du dich so drauf zwängen kannst, oder stellen kannst wie so ein Skateboard und dann damit durch die Gegend fährst. Dann hast du so lange Zügel, die du so halten kannst, wie so ein Roller. Im Grunde ist es das schon. Ich glaube, das setzt sich durch. Und wie finden die Pferde dann zu dir? Weil das wäre Uber Horse zum Beispiel. Perfekt, stimmt. Die müssten ja zu dir finden. Das ist die Frage wie. Das ist gar nicht so dumm. Vielleicht weil man denen so was einbaut, ins Gehirn stampft und dann mit so kleinen Stromschlägen kriegen sie dann angezeigt, ob die jetzt rechts oder links müssen. Oder du packst halt so eine Möhre aus. Oder einfach eine Möhre. Eine Möhre im Rucksack und wedelst die so rum. Naja, oder. Und dann geht so Taxi und dann kommt eines dieser winzig kleinen Pferde angaloppiert und dann kannst du damit irgendwo hingaloppieren. Eine Idee, wir machen das quasi wie Straßenbahnen mit den Stromnetzen drüber. Nur dass es quasi ein, also über jeder Strasse gibt es so Seile und an denen hängen halt Möhren. Also auf so kleinen, da ist dann so ein Rad oben auf dem Seil, wie man das kennt von Seilbahnen oder Liften. Ja, wo immer ein Abstand was ist, ja. Dann hat man oben so ein Rad drauf und dann hat man unten eine Möhre. Ja. Und quasi, dass du führst das Pferd dann zu dir nach Hause. Und dann kannst du eine Adresse eingeben und dann weißt die Möhre wohin und das Pferd folgt der Möhre. Finde ich richtig gut. Nur manchmal müssen die eine erreichen, damit die nicht sehen, dass das System ripped ist, sondern dass die schon auch mal das Erfolg des Lebens bekommen. Sehr aufwendig. Das ist natürlich eine super Idee. Ich glaube auch, dass man Pferde viel sinnvoller einsetzen kann, so diese ganzen Aufgaben, die wir, wir haben ja, sag ich mal, die Hunde sind ja momentan stark überlastet, Blindenhunde, Bombenhunde, Krankheitshunde, Leichenzughunde, alles machen Hunde, wohingegen zum Beispiel Biber nichts tun. Die arbeiten nicht für uns, die bauen keine Dämme, die suchen keine Bomben, die suchen keine Bomben in Dämmen, nichts, gar nichts. Wobei Bombenbiber auch einfach der Bobi auch einfach der bessere Name wäre. Absolut, ja. Wenn du sagst, okay, fuck, es wird ernst, hol die Bombenbiber. Da weiss man sofort, ui, okay, jetzt sitzt es wirklich ernst. Finde ich richtig gut, warum macht man nicht da mehr? Und zum Beispiel auch hier die Idee des Blindenpferdes, dass sich Blinde einfach direkt aufs Pferd setzen. Oder auch der Blindenbiber, für den ich auch wieder wäre. Der Blibi, wo die direkt wissen, wo sie hingehen und man sich draufsetzen kann. Und der Biber auch einfach Bescheid weiß. Es gibt so viele Tiere, die ungenutztes Potenzial haben.
Blinde wollen ja weiterhin gehen, da verstehe ich nicht, warum die... Warum? Ja, es sind ja auch Menschen mit Beinen, die können ja die Füsse vertreten, wobei wenn die Pferde, hier sind wir wieder beim grössten Ding, wenn die so klein sind, wie ich mir das gerade vorstelle, ist es auch eher wie diese Kinder auf diesen kleinen Babys auf Fahrrädern, die man ja, man zwängt ja Kinder schon im Babyalter auf Fahrräder mittlerweile, diese Laufräder. Genau. Und so ist es ja schlecht mit den Pferden eigentlich vor. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das sogar das ursprüngliche Fahrrad war. Erst waren alle Fahrräder Laufräder, also dass auch Erwachsene sich da draufgesetzt haben und dann so gerannt sind nebenbei. Und dann kam erst das Pedalsystem. Aber das macht echt Spaß. Das weiß ich auch oft. Ich hatte oft überlegt, weil ich war ja junger Filmemacher, sagen wir mal so, ja. Ja, sagen wir mal so, sehr vereinfacht. Bleiben wir mal bei, sagen wir mal so. Es war nämlich so, dass immer wenn man so ein Poesiealbum in die Hand gedrückt bekommen hat von Mitschülerinnen und Mitschülern, dann stand da immer drin, was ich mal werden möchte. Und das weißt du ja als Kind nicht. Also woher soll man das wissen? Woher soll man das wissen? Man hat nicht so viel Erfahrung. Nee, man kennt drei Berufe, Polizist, Astronaut, Feuerwehrmann. Und wenn man lieber eher zu Hause bleibt, anstatt auf dem Mond zu fliegen, hat man nicht viele Möglichkeiten. Du schreibst nicht Webdesigner rein. Ich war sehr stolz auf mich, dass ich als eines der wenigen Kinder noch einen vierten Beruf kannte und den sogar aussprechen konnte, nämlich Regisseur. Regisseur. Deswegen habe ich immer Regisseur geschrieben, ohne genau zu wissen, was es ist. Ich wusste irgendwas mit Filmen und so, das fand ich schon immer cool.
Und dann wollte ich immer Regisseur werden.
Und deswegen irgendwann, als ich dann rückwirkend
gelernt habe, was dieser
Beruf ist, dann war ich fasziniert
vom Filmemachen, aber nur weil ich wusste,
das steht jetzt schon in zehn
Poesiealben drin. Also musste
ich rückwirkend meinen eigenen Wunsch erfüllen.
Also du magst die Idee, ein Regisseur
zu sein, lieber als wirklich Regisseur zu sein,
aber nicht aus dem Grund, warum andere
die Idee besser finden, wegen Ruhm
Vielen Dank. rückwirkend meinen eigenen Wunsch erfüllen. Also du magst die Idee eines Regisseurs zu sein lieber als wirklich Regisseur zu sein, aber nicht aus dem Grund, warum andere die Idee besser finden, wegen Ruhm und so, sondern einfach reverse engineieren, weil du den Begriff schreiben kannst. Weil ich wollte mir nicht die Blöße geben, dass ich dann zehn Jahre später Melanie nochmal sehe und dann sage, ja was machst du jetzt? Ja, ich bin jetzt doch Astronaut geworden. Und sie, aha, in meinem Poesiealbum hast du aber Regisaurer geschrieben.
Hast du Regisseur falsch geschrieben? Und dann so, und deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt muss ich auch Filme machen, jetzt ist eigentlich meine Zukunft schon in Stein gemeißelt. Und dann habe ich überlegt, ich will irgendwie so einen Actionfilm machen mit so Superhelden und dann dachte ich mir auch so, weil ich habe so von Greenscreen-Technologie gehört, auch bei Herr der Ringe und so habe ich dann gesehen, Making of, Und dann dachte ich, wie geil wär's, wenn du ein komplett grünes Fahrrad hast und dann auf dem Fahrrad sitzt und dann wie so ein Laufrad so ganz schnell mit grossen Schritten rennst. Aber sonst in dem Film alles normal ist, nur die Menschen da rennen kommen. Das Fahrrad trägt ja und dann dachte ich mir, man könne einfach mit dem Computer dann einfach das grüne Fahrrad einfach entfernen. Ja, stimmt. So einfach wie das geht Und dann sehen die so aus, als würden die so mit ganz grossen Schritten durch die Gegend laufen. Und das war meine Idee, weil meine Grundidee war immer, ich wollte Star Wars machen, aber halt nicht so, dass man merkt, dass es Star Wars ist schon, dass es was gibt. Deswegen habe ich alle Elemente, die in Star Wars cool sind, genommen und habe sie leicht abgeändert. Also ich dachte mir zum Beispiel, statt einem Lichtschwert gibt es die Lichtpeitsche. Oh ja, aber es ist genau wie mein Herr der Ringe Roman, wo es genau die Szene gibt aus Bruchthal, nur halt nicht mit Du hast meinen Bogen, sondern Du hast meine Armbrust, Du hast meine Axt gab es auch nicht, sondern Du hast meinen Morgenstern und es gab halt so drei andere Sachen. Genau, es waren aber auch basically Zwerge, die hießen dann irgendwie Gnome oder sowas, Elfen, das war sehr einfach, weil man konnte es wieder back to the basics. Da hat Tolkien dir schon den Stallpass geben. Hat mir das New Paul gegeben. Ich muss gerade bei diesen Freundembüchern, habe ich wahrscheinlich schon mal erzählt, aber man hat es ja auch dann mal den Eltern gegeben, dieses Freundebuch. Zumindest war es bei uns so, dass man das auch mal dann der Mutter, dem Vater gegeben hat. Und die haben, oder von Freunden zu den Eltern, und die haben dann meistens bei Schwarm reingeschrieben, halt den Ehepartner. Außer meine Mutter, der mein Schwarm hingeschrieben hat, Captain Jack Sparrow. Was rückblickend. Was auch den Kreis vollständig macht, wie du zu deiner Liebe zur Flut der Karibik kommen bist. Als Vaterersatz, als Liebhaber deiner Mutter. Das ist ja großartig. Was aber auch viele Kreise schliesst, lustigerweise. Also nicht nur, was diesen Podcast anbelangt, sondern auch viel zum Verhältnis zu meinem Vater, zu meiner Mutter erklärt. Aber auch mein Vater, der das wahrscheinlich nie gesehen hat oder sich auch gedacht hat, was ist denn da los? Das ist ja perfekt, das ist ja klassischer Ehegig. Und was hast du geschrieben? Na, dich natürlich, Schatz. Nee, ist nicht so wichtig. Essen ist fertig, Essen ist auch fertig. Jake Sparrow. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass... Sie hat Captain Jake Sparrow. Oh, natürlich, mega gut, ja, ja. Captain, da merkt man, die Liebe ist echt. Die Liebe war real. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Jack Sparrow so eine Sexbombe ist, dass der so als Partner war. Ich dachte eigentlich, wenn dann eher Will Turner oder so, aber na klar, dieser Abenteuercharakter, dieser Renegade Outlaw ist natürlich auch immer gut. Wir arbeiten ja immer noch intensiv an unseren Sex-Erotik-Geschichten, wo wir natürlich auch solche ... Wo Captain Jack Sparrow keine Rolle spielt hat, bislang. Wo wir natürlich auch auf der Suche sind, auf welche Figuren fahren Menschen erotisch ab. Da müsste man natürlich auch mal so diese Poesiealben durchforsten, was da alles drinsteht. Mark Forster, David Hasselhoff, welche Leute, Janine Twain ... Ja, lass uns Poesiealben durchgucken, lass uns gucken, was fünf- bis sechsjährige Menschen schreiben, wen sie sexuell attraktiv finden. Das ist, glaube ich, die richtige. Irgendwo muss man ja mit der Recherche anfangen. Ja, lass uns nicht da anfangen. Momentan sind wir beide bei null. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, haben wir beide von Erotik gar keine Ahnung. Speak for your fucking self. Jede Recherche, auch in Kinderschuhen, glaube ich, würde uns da noch weiterhelfen. Ja, genau. Ich glaube nur auch aus legalen Gründen, aus rechtlichen Gründen. Das hatten meine Poesie-Alben gar nicht schwarm. Wir werden vielleicht die Ü18-Version. Das ist ja perfekt. Rhythmisch macht meine Lieblings-Sex-Stellung auch keinen Sinn, wenn wir sind Kinder-Alben. Aber das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, weil du Facebook-ähnlich dann schon so die ersten Kontakte knüpfen kannst, weil dann gibt dir dein Schwarm ihr Poesiealbum und was schreibst du dann da rein? Ist ja ganz gut eigentlich bei uns, nichts dergleichen. Wir hatten bayerische, prüde, katholische Poesiealbum. Aber wäre das nicht geil, weil der Trend geht ja auch wieder weg jetzt von hin zum eher analogen, also gefühlt, man
dieses, ah, ob sich online
unterhalten und so und online
über Apps kennenlernen. Sagt das den Hörern
unseres Online-Podcasts? Ne, aber ich meine
jetzt sowas wie, ne, ja,
klar, natürlich, also das wächst ja weiterhin,
aber ich glaube, so dieses analoge,
jetzt auch nach der Pandemie so mal wieder
rausgehen und sowas, der
Wunsch wächst schon, deswegen glaube ich, wäre sowas geil, wieder so ein Little-Freunde-Buch zu haben, nur halt wirklich darauf auszudaten. Stell dir mal vor, du hast so was und es hat sich durchgesetzt und du gibst einfach so eine Frau, die du in der Bar siehst, die dir gefällt, dieses Buch und sagst, hast du Lust, da reinzuschreiben? Und es ist sofort bisschen kinky, man schreibt auch ... Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das so ein gängiger Pick-up-Artist-Trick ist im Sinne von, du musst aus der Menge rausstechen, ich hab hier ein Poesiealbum. Aber kann sein, ich finde die Linie nicht schlecht, also da nochmal den Haken auszuwerfen, ja, warum nicht, und du hast dann direkt so, ich hatte den Poesiealbum, gab es ja dann auch so gebrandet, so Spider-Man und Snoopy. Diddle. Und ich hatte den Fisch, der seine Schuppen verliert. Kennst du den Regenbogen-Schuppenfisch? Der Regenbogen-Fisch! Aber was war das Ding nochmal? Dem fehlt eine Schuppe oder hat der ein... Ich weiß nicht, aber ist das nicht so silbern funkelnd eine... Oder hat er denn nur eine Schupp, die glänzt, geglänzt hat? Nicht googeln, nicht googeln, nicht googeln, nicht googeln. Ja, wow, dann wird das jetzt, we're in for a ride then. Ich weiß nicht mehr. Oder war das so ein grauer Schwanennummer, dass alle funkeln, nur der kleine Fisch nicht? Nee, nee, nee, nee, der hat funkelnde Schuppen und gibt die Leuten, der reißt die sich raus und gibt die einem anderen Fisch, der glaube ich, oder anderen, nee, ich glaube anderen Meeresstieren, ich glaube der trifft so eine Makrele, die sagt, ich bin hässlich und grau und dann reißt er sich einen Regenstuppen Schuppen. Wie hast du eine Schuppe kannst du dir vor das Gesicht halten, sowas. Was natürlich als Botschaft auch, also reißt du deine eigenen Körperteile raus und schenkst sie anderen Leuten, damit sie ihn auch gut hin. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich nicht mehr. Ich habe dann meinem Schweizer Freundeskreis mal die Geschichte von Sankt Martin erzählt. Und die... Werdere Urlaube, Alter. Nee, nee, nee, komm. Ihr esst Käse und Stefan, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal die Geschichte des heiligen Sankt Martin. Nein, aber wir haben so über, es gab irgendwie so einen Feiertag, keine Ahnung, da habe ich über Sankt Martin erzählt und das bei uns auch immer das reenacted wurde. Wir hatten dann wirklich damals im Kindergarten kam eine Blaskapelle, die Sankt Martin, die favorite, und es gibt sehr viele Sankt Martin Songs. Wirklich? Ich kenne keinen einzigen. Ist nicht, doch dieses ganze, ich gehe mit meiner Laterne, meine Laterne mit mir, Sankt Martin, Sankt Martin, die ganzen Hits halt, du kennst sie was und dann meinten das wäre eine sehr deutsche geschichte dass er nicht seinen ganzen mantel gibt was die klarere botschaft gewesen wäre ja aber es hat natürlich auch noch diesen realismusanspruch weil es ja offensichtlich kalt war in der lore und er irgendwie auch noch selber irgendwie überleben musste und deswegen nur die Hälfte des Mantels. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie zieht man diesen halben Mantel an und wie hilft der und so weiter. Ich kenne es als Umhang, ehrlich gesagt. Der ist ein bisschen leichter zu teilen, aber es stimmt schon, weil beide frieren am Ende eigentlich. Es ist nicht einfach los, beide sterben. Und es ist wirklich nur die Hälfte. Und für diese Geschichte, die ja eh sehr platt ist und jetzt nicht wirklich. Ich meine, ich glaube, es geht ja eher um die Metapher, um das Bild, dass man seinen Wohlstand teilt, nicht gib den Armen alles, was du hast. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch nicht die richtige Botschaft, sondern teil das, was du hast mit anderen und nicht hier ist mein Pferd, hier ist alles. Nee, aber er hat ja noch ein Pferd, er kann ja schnell ins Waren. Ja, er ist ja auch reich.
Ich weiß nicht, wer Martin eigentlich überhaupt war.
Martin.
Ich meine, der war ja damals noch nicht Sankt Martin, der war einfach nur Martin.
Also der war halt einfach ein Typ.
Oder war der was? Ich kann nicht erinnern, was der für ein Beruf war.
Und was war sein zweites Wunder?
Stimmt, du brauchst ja immer zwei Wunder, um vom Vatikan zu gelten.
Mein Vorschlag wäre, das hochzusetzen auf drei. Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist die schlimmste Situation für irgendjemanden in so Bibelzeiten. Du hast ein Wunder, hast du im Gepäck. Perfekt, gemacht, cool, alle kennen dich. Und jetzt natürlich the difficult second wonder. Was kommt jetzt als zweites? Weil du musst jetzt deliveren, alle sagen ja, ja, ja. Und wenn es nicht passiert, passiert es nicht. Obwohl, ist das ein Wunder, dass man jemandem seinen Mantel gibt? Ja, aber er muss ja was gemacht haben. Vielleicht war es auch nicht einer seiner Wunder. Ja, aber vielleicht hat es auch jemandem gereicht. Früher war auch noch die Messlatte nicht so hoch. Ich glaube, der hat dann einfach irgendwie so einen Knopf mit Punjabi MC gefunden und gesagt hat, das ist das Wort Gottes und alle, okay. Aber ist für unsere Vatikan-Sitcom ja gut, wo wir mal überlegt hatten, dass die Wanderbusters, die zwei Leute, die immer den Bewerbungen nachgehen, in der ungeliebten Abteilung der Schweizer Garde, whatever.
Oh, das sind ja geile Sidekicks, kommt immer so einer von der Schweizer Garde mit.
Den die immer eher belustigt verabschieden oder sowas, weil er doch eher von Gaukler ist.
Und in jeder Folge muss er mit seiner Hellebarde irgendjemanden niederstrecken. Egal was, aber... Was nie hinhaut, weil alle Schusswaffen haben. Aber die beiden, die Busters, die dann rumlaufen und versuchen zu falsifizieren, dass es sich nicht wirklich um Wunder gehalten hat. Und bei denen finde ich auch lustig... Meistens Strom. Meistens unisolierte Kabel ist meistens die Erklärung für das Wunder. Und dann ist auch immer die Frage, ist es das erste oder zweite Wunder? Und wahrscheinlich sind die zweiten Wunder eher immer so ein bisschen lazy, weil auch wenn das erste cool gewesen ist, die Chance, dass man nochmal eins vollbringt, ist natürlich nicht so groß. Ich meine, was macht man dann, probiert man dann rum, versucht man mal auf Wasser zu laufen, gibt mir mal einen Blinden, gib mir mal irgendeinen Blinden. Hi! Jetzt, ja, los geht's. Ich leg mal Zeigefinger und Mittelfinger auf deine Stirn. 3, 2, 1, go, jetzt sehnt. Siehst du was? Nee. Verdammt nochmal. Bring mir noch den Nächsten, bring mir den Nächsten. Bring mir irgendwie so einen Einarmigen oder so. Ist auch, glaube ich, wie so ein Sternenrestaurant, wo du auch ein gutes Team brauchst, um den nächsten Stern zu bekommen. Ja, ich sag, Martin hat nur von seinem Team gelebt. Brauchst du ein gutes Team, was dir auch dann die nächsten Blinden besorgt, also was dich auch in Situationen, was das Glück herausfordert, was dich in Situationen schubst, wo es auch easy ist, mal so ein... Und jetzt kommen wir zu einer anderen Gruppe, nämlich die Wunderagentur. Das Spin-Off. Die man einschalten kann, wenn man sagt, so eine Art Künstleragentur, die sagen, ah, sie haben schon ein Wunder, wir helfen ihnen zweiten und die einen dann so PR-mässig auch an die Hand nehmen. Wir fordern das Glück heraus. Genau, und die einen dann einerseits sich um das zweite Wunder kümmern im Sinne von, überlass das mal mir, wir machen das schon, die die Anträge machen und dann auch das Heiligenbild dann designen und so, das ist eigentlich schon nicht schlecht. Und dann haben wir zwei verfeindete Gruppierungen, einmal die Vatikan-Wonderbusters und die Wonderboys, die die Wunder, die die Heiligen unterstützen und die konkurrieren miteinander. Ja und wie die konkurrieren, auch nervig, dass man so Wunder am Fließband, das ist die industrielle Wunderkultur, die gefällt dem Vatikan natürlich gar nicht. Ach Gott, der da hinten ist auch von den Wonder Boys. Das ist wieder so eine Aktion.
Wahrscheinlich wieder unisolierte Kabel.
Okay, los geht's.
Komm, lass uns mal angucken, was sie vorbereitet haben.
Ein sprechender Fasan!
Was ist mit dem Typen da hinten, der die Lippen leicht bewegt?
Ach so, du meinst, die Wonder Boys, die machen richtig auch Fakes.
Wir fordern das Glück heraus.
Das kann jetzt jeder auslegen, wie er möchte.
Vielleicht auch das, zweiter Story-Arc. Die Wonder Boys sind am Anfang wirklich gläubige Menschen, die halt wirklich Heilige unterstützen wollen, aber mehr und mehr werden sie übernommen von dem neuen Chef, der mehr Cash will und der dann so sagt, ja, fag das auch mal so. Ja, der hat doch schon ein Wunder, mein Gott, das zweite, jetzt lass es mal schneller durchschneunig. der die Regeln, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen lockerer auslegt. Ja, genau. Und dann gibt es noch eine dritte Organisation,
The Wonder Girls, die dann sagen, nein, die Wonder Boys sind Heretiker, wir wollen die echten Heiligen finden. Die sprechen auch nur Latein. Die werden nicht mehr untertitelt. Das ist wie Barbaren. Es ist ja auch gut, dass man auch Serien, wo man gewisse Teilaspekte mochte, die einfach übernimmt. Und deswegen reden die zum Beispiel nur Latein. Ja, das finde ich gut. Obwohl eigentlich alle Latein sprechen, aber nur die sprechen tatsächlich Latein. Die sprechen die ganze Zeit Latein. Und die anderen verstehen auch kein Wort. Die verstehen kein Wort. Was? Verstehe ich nicht. Was, Herr Köttisch, auf der Mauer heftig, heftig spritzt. Auf der Mauer, auf der Lauer. Was? Wie bei uns bei der Latein-Schulaufgabe, wo die Schiffe gegen die Steine geflogen sind. Wo der Lehrer auch meinte, ist dir nicht kurz im Moment gedacht, dass vielleicht nicht eher die Steine auf die Schiffe fliegen? Oh, das... Ach ja, stimmt. Das bringt mich jetzt... Weil natürlich macht man sich... Die Schiffe fliegen auf die Steine. Wirklich. Man sollte meinen, dass ... Das hat Caesar geschrieben, wirklich. Caesar war jetzt auch nicht der Cleverste. Naja, er hat beschrieben, was er sieht. Jetzt, ne, kann man sagen, dass einem gesunder Menschenverstand helfen sollte bei der Lateinübersetzung. Man muss aber auch sagen, dass man so sehr in dem, ich schlage jetzt die Wörter nach, weil es war ja ein Wörterbuch erlaubt, man war da so drin, in diesem Modus einfach aufzuschreiben, was man da gerade übersetzt, dass man nicht den Satz danach nochmal gelesen hat und überlegt hat, ob das so Sinn ergibt. Und dann ging es eh immer um den über den Limes, wo ich jetzt auch nicht genau weiß, wo der war, wie hoch der war. Kam auch eine Meldung zum Thema Limes, weil wir haben über den Limes hergezogen. Wir haben schon wieder über den Limes gesprochen. Wir haben gesagt, wir haben keinen Bock auf den Limes, dieser legendäre Wall, so europäische chinesische Mauer. Genau. Wo die Chinesen kommen und sagen, ach, ihr habt auch eine Mauer? Ja, eine Off-Brand-Mauer, die man nicht aus dem Weltall sieht. Genau, und wir ihnen dann diese peinlichen kniehohen Steine zeigen müssen, wo die Chinesen sagen, das ist eure Mauer? Ja, ja, ja. Da hat auch jemand gesagt, ja, ich bin Historiker oder irgendwas. Und ja, stimmt, ich habe mich damit intensiv beschäftigt. Und ja, ihr habt recht, militärisch ist der Nutzen vergleichsweise gering. Man geht auch eher davon aus, dass es eher eine wirtschaftliche Grenze war.
Also sowas wie eine Ländergrenze zwischen zwei Staaten, wo man dann Zoll zahlen muss oder so.
Und es für die Wagen oder Kutschen durchaus schwer ist, über eine kniehohe Mauer zu geraten.
Aber merkst du, wie sich das Blatt wendet?
Das war, glaube ich, so das, was ich meine. Merkst du, wie sich das Blatt wendet?
Ja, das wendet sich.
Von den Nachrichten, die waren, er erzählt kompletten Quatsch, wie es wirklich war, hinzu, ja, ihr habt schon recht. Ja, entwickelt uns. Langsam müssen unsere Hörer auch zugeben, dass wir hier und da mal was finden. Mal was landen. Also eher so nach dem Prinzip, ein Blindes Hund findet auch mal ein Limes. Ja, ja. Aber gut. Aber es stimmt auch da, die Limes-Forschung, bitte, falls ihr da einen Gegenentwurf habt, falls ihr sagt, doch, der militärische Nutzen ist da, falls sich alle auf dem Boden legen hinter der Mauer und dann geschützt sind, irgendwas.
Wobei, oder meine These, wenn sich alle Historiker mal kurz einmal um 180 Grad drehen könnten und mal in die Zukunft forschen könnten, fände ich mal interessant. Fände ich auch interessant. Nur mal so für zwei Jahre, dass man die, weil man sagt ja manchmal so lapidar, kindisch dahergesagt, guckt man nicht nur so zurück, guckt man mal nach vorne, weil manchmal macht es ja auch Sinn, vielleicht dahin zu gucken, wo man hinläuft, als Zivilisation, als Gesellschaft. Nicht für uns, wir schauen weiter zurück, denn wir müssen zurückschauen, um unsere liebsten Tiere zu sehen, und damit kommen wir zu den Dino News. Oh, wir haben ihn neu aufgenommen. Früher war es ja noch Blutin und Stephans Dino News. Die Dino News, ja, es gibt neue Informationen. Vielen Dank an alle, die uns das geschickt haben. Und zwar im Good Old Österreich gab es folgende Schlagzeile.
Österreichischer Saurier war träge und schwerhörig. War träge und schwerhörig. In der zweiten Hälfte des 19. Jahrhunderts wurden in einem Bergwerk bei Mutmannsdorf in Niederösterreich Überreste eines rund 80 Millionen Jahre alten Dinosauriers entdeckt. Der CT-Scan eines Schädelteils zeigte nun, Strutosaurus Ostraicus war wohl ein recht behäbiger und schlecht hörender Einzelgänger. Also, das muss man sagen. Warum es jetzt wichtig ist, wie gut die hören können, ist mir schleierhaft. Das sind riesige Mordmaschinen, die einfach alles kaputt stampfen und fressen, was ihnen im Weg steht. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, die haben aber nicht so gut gehört, dann ist das einfach nur eine Schmutzkampagne, eine Schmierenkampagne, auf die ich persönlich keinen Bock mehr habe. Also ich verstehe auch nicht, früher war die Meldung ja, wir haben einen neuen Dinosaurier entdeckt. Cool. That's it. Es war cool, Leute haben sich gefreut, Leute sind dahingefahren zur Ausgrabungsstätte, Leute haben Knochen in die Kamera gehalten. Nein, jetzt ist es nicht mehr das, jetzt ist es direkt, hm, was können wir direkt mitliefern, was es egal und uncool macht. Schmutzkampagne. Forscher schauen Dinosaurier aus Österreich ins Gehirn. Er war träge und schwerhörig.
Ja, aber er hatte doch bestimmt auch positive Eigenschaften. Also das definiert doch ein Mensch nicht. Er war sehr loyal. Er war träge und schwerhörig, aber er war loyal. Er hat ein wahnsinnig gutes Gedächtnis. Er hat einen großen Penis. Kann man auch mal sagen. Also das finde ich albern, dass man da immer die negativen Sachen rausstellt. Ich fange auf dem Bild, hat er, ist er so, hat cooles Stacheln. So ein cooles Muster. Hat er aber coole Stacheln. Vor allem, was heißt denn schwerhörig? Also im Vergleich zu was? Ja. Jedes Tier hat ein unterschiedlich gutes Gehör. Also du kannst ja nicht bei Tiefen schlechterhören sagen, ein Regenwurm ist schwerhörig. Nee, er hat halt einfach
andere Prioritäten und kann halt vielleicht gut
riechen oder so. Ja, wir sind auch extrem kurzsichtig
im Vergleich zu Adlern zum Beispiel.
Und Mensch ist auch schwerhörig im Vergleich zu
einem Lutz oder so. Ja, warum muss man dann sagen,
man sagt nicht, Menschen sind schwerhörig, sondern
Menschen, das Exemplar,
was sie untersucht haben, schwerhörig,
vielleicht war aber diese
Spezies insgesamt jetzt eher auf der, sagen wir mal, nicht so gut hörenden Seite des Spektrums.
Was okay ist.
Ja.
Was völlig okay ist, wenn man nicht so gut hören kann.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Und Einzelgänger, ja, natürlich.
Früher war das cool, Tyrannosaurus Rex dominiert alleine den ganzen Dschungel.
Und jetzt ist Einzelgänger anscheinend auch irgendwie was Schlechtes oder was, weil er nicht gut hören kann und behäbig ist. Bei der österreichischen Zeitung Der Standard nehmen sie die neuen Erkenntnisse zum Dino aus Mutmannsdorf mit einer Prise Humor und Selbstironie. Hier wird Strutiosaurus aus Triakos in einem Artikel als Gegenteil des Hollywood-Klischees der flinken, durchtriebenden Killermaschine beschrieben. So, jetzt möchte ich mal kurz sagen, Schuster, bleibt bei euren Leisten. Ne, Humor machen andere. Prise Humor und Selbstironie. Das selbe, was wir brauchen, sind Paläontologen, die lustig sind. Selbst Deprecating-Paleontologen brauche ich nicht. Nein. Lustige Paläontologen brauche ich nicht.
Wir alle haben eine Berufswahl getroffen.
Was steht im Poesiealbum?
Steht da Comedian oder steht da Paläontologe?
Oder steht da Hilarious Paläontologe?
Nein, so viel Platz ist in der Spalte nicht.
Also.
Jetzt glaube ich auch nicht, dass der Wort Paläontologe steht.
Das hat ein bisschen zu viele schwierige Buchstaben.
Beschränk dich auf eins.
Aber wir finden das albern und ich sag mal
so, falls ihr irgendwo arbeitet und irgend so eine
Grube habt mit Knochen drin oder so,
dann haut mal bitte ein paar positive
Schlagzeilen raus, wir brauchen das mittlerweile,
wir erleben hier einen schweren Schlag
nach dem anderen, wir brauchen mal sowas wie
hat coole Sägeknochen
oder hat Sägezahnzunge
oder irgendein cooles. Konnte Feuerspeien. Ja, sowas.
Einzige, was noch hilft. Ja, genau, oder
irgendwie in so einem coolen Morgensternschwanz
oder irgendwas cooles mit so, wie so diese
Also, Knochen oder hat Sägezahn, Zunge oder irgendein cooles. Konnte Feuerspein. Ja, sowas im Eppie. Einzige, was noch hilft. Ja, genau, oder irgendwie in so einem coolen Morgensternschwanz oder irgendwas cooles mit so wie so diese oder der konnte die anderen auf dem Rücken werfen, so wie diese Fighting Bots oder so. Der hatte so ein rotierendes Sägeblatt auf dem Rücken oder irgendwas. Der Flurculus konnte als von äusserster Wichtigkeit sein, wenn ein Tier mit der Schwanzkeule auf etwa Konkurrenten oder Angreifer zielen musste. Ach guck mal, diese Schwanzkeule, die Keule am Schwanz, die wird aber erst dann im achten Absatz bei der Universität Wien erwähnt. Mann, ey, Mann, Mann, Mann. Aber der sieht cool aus, sieht fucking cool aus. Keine Anzeichen von einer grauen Haarpracht, Federn oder Crocs. Einfach nur schick, hat so dieses wie ein Ankylosaurus aussieht, auch so geile Stacheln rechts und links. Da habe ich so eine Schwanzkräume. Es ist die kommunikativen Fähigkeiten von Strutosaurus austraicus würden etwa im Bereich von heutigen Schildkröten liegen. Na gut, das ist nicht, warum du das jetzt vorlesen musstest. Das ideal. Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Kannst du ja auch vorher noch mal lesen und dann vorlesen. Verstehe jetzt nicht. Gehörschnecke. Achtung, möglich seien aber auch andere Formen der Kommunikation, etwa über ihre Knochenplatten. Telepathie. Was? Knochenplatten. Ja, wie? Haben die aufeinandergeschleunert. Die kommunizieren über Knochenplatten? Ja, wie? Haben die aufeinander gestorben? Die kommunizieren über Knochenplatten.
Ja, jetzt
verstehe ich nicht, warum.
Aber das merkt man auch, dass du dich an jeden
Schreitern jetzt kreist. Oder halt so wie der
Regenbogenfisch, der halt dann die Knochenplatten
austeigt, wie so ein Handout.
Ich google jetzt den Regenbogenfisch, ob du das willst oder nicht,
weil ich will wissen, was er gemacht hat.
Ich habe neulich bei Twitter nämlich so ein Bild gesehen von dem und da habe ich sehr viele Erinnerungen gehabt. Naja, was hat er nochmal gemacht? Oh, fuck, ey. Ah, Mann, ey, das ist echt ärgerlich mit diesen dummen Dinosauriern, das nervt. Der Regenbogenfisch lernt verlieren. Dem gehen doch meine ich die Schuppen aus. Weil er sie alle herschenkt, oder das? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Reichen wir nach. Brauchen wir da mal ein Remake? Es ist viel Google-Arbeit, das herauszufinden. Es gibt viele Remakes, Hollywood ist auf der Suche nach alten Stoffen, neue aufgetischt. Warum nicht der Regenbogenfisch? Jetzt mal als Badass-Version.
Weil es gibt ja jetzt auch zum Beispiel Prince von Bel-Air, kommt jetzt auch als Drama raus.
Also die gleiche Story, aber eben nicht mehr als Comedy, sondern als Drama.
Warum jetzt nicht auch einfach mal sagen, der Regenbogenfisch einfach als Thriller, als Drama, als Wurfsternfisch unter Wasser findet Nemo in Badass?
Warum denn nicht?
Das ist Horror mehr, also Horrorfilm.
Ja, Horrorfilm. Der muss mit seinen Körperteilen zahlen. Hier steht auch dieses Buchgefühl 84% der Nutzern. Und dann steht hier, darunter kann man jetzt Bewertungen von 1 bis 5 Sternen geben. Wie errechnet Google daraus jetzt, wie viel Prozent der Nutzer das ... Ach so, also ab wie viel Sternen gefällt es dir? Ja, ab wie viel Sternen es denn dann gefällt mir? Sind drei Sterne gefällt mir? Und wenn ja, ist das fünf Sterne-System dann nicht beknackt, weil drei ist ja immer noch eine schlechte Bewertung, aber ist immerhin mehr als die Hälfte bei fünf. Schwierig. Apropos Reboots, Remakes. Wuhu! Okay, ja, da freue ich mich sehr drauf, denn wir starten jetzt eine altbekannte Rubrik, denn wir haben damals, jetzt reicht es nicht für eine ganze Folge, wir hatten damals bereits Antenne Asgaban erfolgreich gemacht, es kommen noch andere Sachen, Antenne Alabastia, Antenne Auenland, das kommt alles noch. Aber jetzt kommt erst mal. Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, dingelilingeling, Antenne Agent Smith.
Ja, völlig richtig unsere Matrix-Rubrik, denn wir haben Matrix Resurrections gesehen. Wir haben einen Plural im Titel und einen Film, der große Wellen schlägt und der mich hingerissen hat. Also ein unglaublicher Film. Ich hatte Redebedarf und ich habe dich mehr oder weniger dazu genötigt, ihn auch zu sehen. Ich hoffe, du nimmst es mir nicht allzu übel, aber ich glaube, als Kinder der Neunziger, als Kinder der Matrix-Welt, die alle damit aufgewachsen sind und damit erstmal so in viele Science-Fiction-Themen eingestiegen sind, muss man auch einfach diese Serie bis zu Ende mitverfolgen und ich finde, es lohnt sich. Also man muss dazu sagen, dass ich viele Fragen habe. Und ich aber auch nach den ersten drei Filmen viele Fragen hatte. Also der erste ist mir noch sehr gut in Erinnerung eigentlich, der erste Matrix-Film. Die anderen beiden hat man noch so mal geguckt, mal, habe ich jetzt aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht häufiger mal gesehen, sondern einmal. Und ich behaupte auch, dass ich wahrscheinlich sehr viel davon verschlafen, geschlafen habe. Und ich könnte jetzt nicht die Geschichte von zwei und drei so rezipieren, was mir rückblickend viele Steine in den Weg gelegt hat für Resurrections. Absolut. Ich habe auch die Hälfte des Films versucht, mich zu erinnern, wie der dritte Teil geendet ist, um zu wissen, wo die anknüpfen, konnte mich aber schlicht nicht erinnern. Aber wieder erzählt, wieder alles, wenn man über den Film ja eins sagen kann, der nimmt den Zuschauer an die Hand. Ja, also man muss ja sagen, Matrix hat ja immer das grosse Problem, dass diese Matrix super interessant ist, diese Fake-Welt, alles nur ein Programm, cool, sobald man aus der Matrix ist, ist auch Neo ja einfach nur ein random Typ, der ist ja nichts Besonderes. Mit so einem Klinkeradapter hinten drin. Der ist ja nur in der Matrix, der Auserwählte, der Virus, der Bug, der immer wiederkehrt, der das System resettet, bla bla bla, alles super cool. Ja. Nur halt in dieser normalen Welt ist ja halt nichts. Und da muss man halt immer und immer wieder Gründe finden, warum man überhaupt in die Matrix muss. Weil die Matrix ist ja eigentlich in der Überwelt Teil eines Kraftwerks. Kraftwerks. Das ist so, wie wenn in einem Kraftwerk halt irgendwo ein Programm läuft, damit die Batterien laufen. Genau. Und das ist ja für die Welt ein so kleiner Aspekt, dass man sich denkt, warum müssen die denn da ständig wieder rein? Und der Film ist eigentlich immer mit der Brechstange am Hebeln, sich zu überlegen, warum müssen die jetzt in die Matrix rein, die ja so cool ist und so narrativ, so interessant, für die Welt aber eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig. Ziehen die nicht alle Energie daraus? Ich glaube ja, ja. Dann ist es schon ein wichtiger Aspekt für die Welt. Ja, absolut, klar. Aber du kannst ja sagen, wir sprengen das Kernkraftwerk in die Luft oder irgendwie sowas. Ja, das verstehe ich auch. Aber es ist schwierig. Aber der neue Film ist super strange. Genau, also ich würde mich sehr gefreut, ich würde mich bedanken, dass du mich dazu gezwungen hast, weil ich hätte ihn wahrscheinlich nicht angeschaut, habe aber damals den Trailer sehr gerne geguckt und verfolgt natürlich auch die Wachowskis sehr.
Hör auf ein paar Ecken, weil auch der, kann ich sagen wer, aber einer, mit dem ich Ahr gearbeitet habe, ist Nachbar quasi von Lana Wachowskis in Berlin.
Wow.
Die natürlich einfach...
Wie viele Verbindungen, du hast ja letztens noch mit dem Line-Producer gesprochen.
Ja, die Nachbar quasi von Lana Bickowski in Berlin. Wow. Die natürlich einfach... Wie viele Verbindungen, du hast ja letztens noch mit dem Line-Producer gesprochen.
Ja, genau.
Unsere Script-Supervisorin hat auch mal für Lana gearbeitet.
Und man hört immer von allen Ecken, wie cool Lana ist und wie weird auch,
dass sie die weirdesten Partys feiert und die seltsamsten Gestalten da zu Gast hat usw.
Jedenfalls habe ich mich darauf sehr gefreut, weil das ist ja auch,
Das ist ein Wetter. wie Lana ist und wie weird auch, und dass sie die weirdesten Partys feiert und die seltsamsten Geschalten da zu Gast hat und so weiter und so weiter. Jedenfalls habe ich mich darauf sehr gefreut, weil das hat sie ja auch selber geschrieben und directed. Ja. Und die Musik kam von Tom Tick war unter anderem, was ich ja nach wie vor auch geil fand und so. Und ich wollte mich vor allem bei dir bedanken, weil es ein Autorenfilm ist, ein Autorinnenfilm. Und ganz ehrlich, ich hab den, für mich war es ein irres Kinoerlebnis. Und ich, weil, und da muss ich sagen, also man kann über den Film sehr viel sagen und auch sehr viel blöd finden daran, aber was ich total mochte, war, wie geil der all in geht. Aber absolut. Der geht komplett komplett All-In. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin es satt,
immer diese breit gewaschene Studio beauftragt etwas,
weil es gut läuft,
holt sich eine Regisseur, Regisseurin dazu,
die aber nicht so willig dahinterstecken,
für die es eher ein Sprungbrett ist,
um irgendwann eigene Sachen zu machen,
holt Drehbuchautoren, Autorinnen zu,
die dann zu sechs dran schreiben usw.
Am Ende hast du was breit gewaschenes, was alles sein will, Fanservice ist usw. auf einer IP-Beruf von jemand anderem, der damit Herzberg hintersteckt usw. Habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und fucking Matrix geht all in. Geht all in, aber auch mit so einer ganz merkwürdigen Attitüde, weil die Hintergrundgeschichte war ja die, dass Lana Warkowski im Grunde erpresst wurde. Ja. Das Studio hat gesagt, wir machen Teil vier. Warner Brothers hat gesagt, wir machen Teil vier mit oder ohne dir, dich. Und sie hat gesagt, ja, okay, das ist mein Projekt, dann will ich es schon selber machen, habe aber jetzt auch nicht wirklich was zu erzählen. Und das ist schon interessant, weil ich glaube, es ist der selbstreferentiellste Film der Welt.
Kein Film ist so sehr Bruch der vierten Wand und weil... Aber ohne zu Onden, also nein, der ist so hard onden aus. Ja, aber ich meine... Nein, nein, nein, weil Neo ist am Anfang des Teils wieder in der Matrix und er ist Videospielproduzent und hat das, was wir als die drei Matrix-Filme kennen, hat er in der Welt als Videospiel programmiert. Und das ist für mich das Verwirrendste der Welt gewesen, weil für uns alle, zumal der Film, also, das hast du ja schon angetiess, Matrix 1, 2 und 3 laufen die ganze Zeit auch in Matrix 4 jetzt. Genau. Im Hintergrund. Wir sehen immer wieder Ausschnitte aus den ersten Filmen. Aber nicht nur teilweise dazwischen montiert als Erinnerung, sondern auch teilweise in den Kulissen läuft der Film. Weil die Filme gibt es in der Welt, aber eben als Videospiel. Ja, und sprich immer wenn die Figuren über Videospiel reden, müssen wir als Zuschauer denken, aha, die Filme sind gemeint. Alles, was in den Filmen passiert ist, wissen auch die Figuren, aber es ist halt nur ausgedacht. Macht aber auch Sinn, weil sonst müsstest du ihn jetzt so einem Regisseur machen. Das wäre ja albern. Nee, er ist ja Programmierer, er ist ja Hacker. Hacker hat also jetzt ... Ja, ist schon was anderes, schräg genommen, egal.
Er hat als Game-Designer jetzt dieses Spiel erfunden.
Und was ich immer wahnsinnig verwirrend fand, ist ja, dass die Matrix ja nichts anderes ist. Also angenommen, man übersetzt die Matrix mal kurz mit Zuckerbergs Metaverse, ne, so eine Welt, in die du eintauchen kannst, ist ja das Spiel, was er da programmiert hat, ist wahrscheinlich, also ich habe mir das immer gedacht, er hat quasi eine Matrix, so ein Second Life. Ja, genau, da wird's kompliziert. Aber er hat so eine Art Matrix, weil am Anfang des Films sehen wir so ein Segment, wo wieder die coolen Actionhelden eintauchen in irgendeine Welt und Und das wird dann aber abgebrochen und wir hören, ah, das war ein Modular oder irgendwie so ein Testlauf der Videospiel-Engine. Also so eine Art Matrix, die aber in einer anderen Matrix ist. Neo ist ja als Thomas Anderson wieder in einer Matrix am Anfang. Wir sehen ja die normale Welt, wie wir sie kennen. Das muss ja eine Matrix sein, in der es aber eine zweite Matrix gibt. Und jetzt der Film beginnt mit, du sollst jetzt den vierten Teil programmieren, im Sinne von, aha, wir machen gerade den vierten Film auch, wir sehen das ja gerade. Und lustigerweise Warner Brothers, namentlich erwähnt, zwingt uns jetzt dazu, das zu machen. Und sie sagen explizit, wir machen den vierten Teil mit oder ohne dich. Und er sagt, ohne mich können die es nicht machen. Er sagt, oh doch, die können alles. Also eins zu eins, was passiert ist. Entweder das oder einfach, mir fällt gar nicht ein, was ich erzählen soll. Ich finde das mega. Und das Geile ist, der Film pendelt immer zwischen brillant und super offensichtlich unkreativ. Und das vermischt es aber auf irgendeine Art, wo man denkt, was geschieht denn? Ganz ehrlich, unkreativ fand ich den nicht. Man kann ihn teilweise plakativ nennen oder sowas. Jetzt komme ich aber gerade aus einer intensiven Watch-Party von Supernatural, die so krass Das ist natürlich ein anderes Niveau. Die aber auch super lustig krass Meta plötzlich erzählen, plötzlich an einem Filmset stehen von Supernatural, weil die in der Dimension von einem Engel durchgeschickt wurden. Und es ist super lustig, aber auch wahnsinnig on the nose alles. Und wenn man dann Matrix kommt, wirkt das wie feinstofflich. Ja, als alles andere. Aber ist doch schon recht. Ist das Plakativ hier und da? Aber ich finde, Unkreativität kann man diesem Film nicht vorwerfen, weil wenn das die Geschichte ist, keine Ahnung, ob die das irgendwann auch in den Interviews so gesagt haben, damit das alles cooler ist oder sowas, aber wenn das die Genese von Matrix 4 war, Warner Brothers zwingt Lana das zu machen und sie sagt, wir machen es mit oder ohne dich, keine Ahnung, mach es und sie macht das dann und macht das zum Thema, finde ich schon ziemlich genial. Und wir haben halt natürlich auch bei diesen Videospiel-Developern, die halt bewusst super überzeichnete Figuren sind, haben wir auch so, es muss immer Bullet Time sein, es muss Bullet Time sein und we made some young people really happy oder so. Also alles super referenziell auf den Film, wo du irgendwann das Gefühl verlierst, jetzt überhaupt einen Film in der Welt zu schauen, wo du denkst, okay, was will dieser Film denn dann selber überhaupt noch sein, weil er macht ja sich zynisch über sich selber lustig, über seine Vorgänger lustig, betont, dass es gar nicht möglich ist, was Neues zu machen. Macht sich über die Zuschauer lustig, macht die Dinge lustig, sagt, ah, die einen wollten nur Action, ja, halt irgendwie Action mit ein bisschen philosophisch drüber gesprengelt, also macht sich selber lustig. Und das ist auch so, der erste war ja noch clever, weil er sich über die Ausbeutung der Menschheit im Kapitalismus lustig macht, which is true, also der erste war ja wirklich ein wahnsinnig cleverer Film, war auch noch philosophisch spannend, hat irgendwie coole Ansätze geliefert und coole Gedankenexperimente wie der erste Purge. Ja, aber vor allem du denkst dir, was, wo will dieser Film, den wir gerade sehen, denn jetzt noch hin?
Weil du hast gerade alles eingerissen. Spoiler, will er nicht. Nirgendwo. Du hast dich zynisch selber über dich selber lustig gemacht, du hast es entzaubert, du hast die vierte Wand eingerissen. Was kann jetzt überhaupt noch passieren? Und da wird spannend. Und ich fand die erste Hälfte wirklich interessant, weil ich mir wirklich auch immer dachte, okay, was passiert jetzt? Und vor allem diese Idee, du hast die Geschichte der Matrix in der Matrix, ist ja eigentlich brillant. Weil er, diese Geschichte ist so ein bisschen, er erinnert sich an das, was passiert ist als Neo, aber sein Therapeut sagt ihm, das hast du dir nur eingebildet. Mit der blauen Brille. Genau, du hast dich zu sehr. Die blaue Brille, ja, du hast dich zu sehr mit deinem eigenen Projekt identifiziert und es kommt zurück.
Und du denkst dir eigentlich, das ist ja genial, weil du denkst ja, die Leute in der Matrix, die sehen den Matrix-Videospiele, denken, oh krass, zum Glück sind wir nicht in der Matrix drin wie in den Spielen. Wir wissen als Betrachter aber, sie sind gerade in der Matrix, und diese Geschichte der Matrix ist Teil des Unterdrückungssystems, dass die Leute in der Matrix sich sicherer fühlen, weil sie diese Unterinstanz mit der Matrix Videospielen haben und denken, ah, wir sind nicht in der Matrix. Weil eine Matrix würde ja nicht zulassen, dass es eine Analogie einer Matrix in der Matrix existiert. Und ich dachte, was passiert ist, dass Neo, weil, wenn ihr uns, warum macht Neo das denn überhaupt, oder Thomas Anderson das denn überhaupt, Thomas Andersson, warum macht er das denn überhaupt? Und ich dachte, geil, die Idee ist, dass sozusagen dadurch, dass diese Matrix-Idee in der Matrix ist, er ganz viele Leute dazu bringen will, die zu verlassen. Weil das wäre echt ein Problem für die Maschinen, wenn jetzt plötzlich alle Menschen aus der Matrix aufkommen. Die Stecker rausziehen. Genau, alle ziehen die Stecker raus, der Strom ist weg, die werden alle besiegt und die Menschheit hätte gewonnen. Das heißt, wenn es Neo geschafft hätte, durch seine Videospiele und dann massenweise rote Pillen, es geschafft hätte, dass alle aufwachen, dann würden plötzlich ganz viele neue Menschen in der normalen Welt sein, die Matrix bricht zusammen und es gibt keinen Strom mehr für die Maschine und man hat gewonnen. Ich dachte mir, okay, das ist vielleicht die Idee. Aber nee. Nee, du warst ganz weit weg. Aber jetzt muss ich mich mal kurz entlarven als jemand, der denkbar umgegangen ist, dieses Format Antenne Agent Smith zu moderieren. Warum macht er irgendwas ... Gute Frage. Sehr gute Frage. Ich habe schon verstanden, dass, ehrlich gesagt, vielleicht auch das Cleverste von diesem Film, dass er gar nicht versucht, diese Fragen zu beantworten, die er im ersten Teil aufwirft und dann einfach eine Love-Story erzählt. Aber warum, ich verstehe nicht, was deren Mission da war. Null, überhaupt nicht. Ganz merkwürdig. Weil er rettet ja, die retten ja niemanden aus der Matrix. Nee, also das war so ein bisschen die Falle, in die ich getappt bin bei dem Film, dass ich dachte, okay, ich habe den Film für cleverer gehalten, als ich dachte. Ich dachte mir auch, weil Keanu Reeves spielt in dem Film ja katastrophal. Der ist ja komplett, als wäre er betäubt, als wäre er betäubt, als würde er sich keine Mühe geben. Ich dachte mir, genial, weil der ist gerade in der Matrix, der ist so total eingeschläfert und katatonisch und kann kein echter Mensch sein, wo du dann so zu Keanu Reeves gehst und sagst, sei mega, wie bewusst schlecht gespielt, dass er einfach ein Glas nimmt und ist dir die Fresse. Genial, weil in dem Moment, in dem er dann aufwacht, dann kann er wirklich wieder leben als echter Mensch, als selber freier Mensch, der einen eigenen Willen hat und nicht in der Matrix ist, aber er hat den gesamten Film keinen Bock und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie jemand am Set steht und sagt, okay, danke, die war's, nach dem, was, weil der immer gleich ist und wirklich, what? Und auch die ganze, weil der muss ja schwierige Dinge spielen, die Welt um ihn bricht zusammen, die Realität ist plötzlich nicht mehr das, was es ist. Und er, what? Also ich weiß nicht, woran das lag, vielleicht war es auch eine bewusste Entscheidung, aber ganz, ganz absurd.
Und jetzt vor allem interessant, wir haben ja die Morpheus-Figur, die Neo dazu bringt aufzuwachen.
Und die gibt es aber nicht mehr, sondern Thomas Anderson programmiert in seinem Videospiel diese Morpheus-Figur, seine eigene Kreation in dem Videospiel.
Und die kommt aus dem Videospiel raus und ist in der Matrix und bringt ihn dazu, aufzuwachen. Und in der echten Welt, also eine Ebene drüber, kommt auch diese digitale Figur dann durch diese Nanoroboter. Weil er ist ja keine wie der alte Morpheus, der ein echter Mensch war, der dann runter in die Matrix geht, geht der neue Morpheus von unten in die echte Welt. Was interessant ist, weil Anderson ja sich seinen eigenen Erwecker programmiert, der ihn dann auch tatsächlich erweckt, was ja eigentlich eine coole Idee ist. Coole Idee, viele coole Ideen. Problem ist natürlich auch, also hier wurden dem Film so ein paar Curveballs hingeworfen, dass Agent Smith, der Namensgeber dieses Podcasts, ja auch nicht mehr mitspielen wollte, beziehungsweise bei einem Theater-Engagement war, aka ich hab gar keinen Bock auf diesen Scheiss. Und Morpheus, der Schauspieler, Namen vergessen, Laurence Fishburne, auch keinen Bock mehr hatte. Ja, klar, natürlich. Und auch nicht am Start ist. So heißt, diese beiden Menschen mussten ersetzt werden. Aiden Smith wurde dann toll gespiegelt. Nein, also auch ein bisschen verwirrt gespielt von Jonathan Groff. Ja, man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, der ist der Einzige, der sich Mühe gibt. So, der ist der Einzige, der weiß, wo ... Neil Patrick Harris fand ich auch nicht so schlecht. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Was ich, also, und visuell fand ich diesen Film wirklich geil. Ich habe ihn auch auf einer richtig coolen Leinwand gesehen in Köln. Da gibt es nämlich die ganzen OV-Filme, die werden in richtig geilen Kinosälen gezeigt. Es haben nicht so viele Plätze, aber es sind so Liegesessel, die man sich zurückstellen kann. Und es ist eine richtig geile, grosse Leinwand. Und cooler Sound, und es war richtig geil, den zu gucken. Vor allem auch hinten raus, so das Finale, fand ich visuell richtig, richtig geil. Ist überraschend, weil ich ... Also, ich fand das nicht so überzeugend, aber ... Doch, ich finde die Ideen geil, wie die Menschen aus den Fenstern fallen, fand ich megacool. Ja, ich finde, der größte ... Ein Fehler des Films war ja, dass man ständig Szenen aus den alten Filmen sieht und sich denkt, die waren geil, die Filme. Das sah cool aus, auch immer dieser Grünstich, diese coolen Kostüme, die damals auch weniger albern gewirkt haben als heute. Und du denkst einfach, coole Filme, also super strange. Und letzten Endes der eigentliche Plot ist, er muss Trinity zusammenfinden, weil aus irgendeinem Grund Neo und Trinity geben so eine Yin-Yang-Einheit. Die sind the one. Genau, die zusammen müssen in der Matrix sein, weswegen Neo überhaupt erst wieder in der Matrix angeschlossen wurde. Und deswegen müssen die zusammen sein und deswegen, ja, der ist in sie verliebt und will sie auch erwecken und das ist dann der eigentliche Plot, rette Trinity aus der Matrix. Ich fand den Film fantastisch, die zweite Hälfte fand ich ein bisschen langweilig, die erste Hälfte fand ich richtig gut. Ich würde
gern mal jemanden sehen, der diesen
Film sieht, ohne die ersten drei Teile
gesehen zu haben. Ich glaube,
verwirrter kann ein Mensch nicht sein,
als nach dem Anblick
dieses Films, der, wo ständig
andere Filme gezeigt werden,
man die ganzen Referenzen nicht hat,
weil der Film ist ja auch reiner Fanservice
mit allen hundert Dingen, aha, blaue
Pille, rote Pille, aha, hier ständig,
du siehst teilweise sogar eins zu eins die Schnitte
Es ist ein, was, hier ständig, du siehst teilweise sogar eins zu eins die Schnitte in den alten Filmen, um zu zeigen, das ist jetzt gerade eine Referenz. Und man denkt sich, ja, das habe ich schon auch verstanden, deswegen schaue ich den Film ja, aber der Film drückt es dir so rein, also ganz absurder Film. Ich wollte ja unbedingt mal das Apartment sehen, in dem Lana Wackowski lebt. Ich will sehen, wie es sich eingerichtet. Es ist ja unnötig zu sein mit deinen Connections. Ich will wissen, wie die eingerichtet ist, was sie macht, was hat die für Hobbys. Ich will jetzt alles wissen, weil ich war so fasziniert, weil ich meine, das ist ja so ein spezieller Geschmack offensichtlich, den sie auch hat, in dem Film auch zum Ausdruck bringt. Mir hat es Spaß gemacht. Ich fand es ein richtig geiles Klimaerlebnis, das zu gucken. Manchmal habe ich das Publikum geguckt, diese verwirrten Gesichter. Viele sind eingeschlafen. Viele Tenet-Momente, wo man einfach so ... Also ich glaube, entweder man versucht, wirklich die Ebenen zu trennen und es zu verstehen, oder man ignoriert das einfach und denkt sich einfach, okay, da knallt jetzt irgendwas. Ganz, ganz strange. Ja, so im letzten Akt habe ich mich auch primär einfach auf Action gefreut und habe dann, weil da hat mir die Story, habe ich verloren. Absolut, und aber ich habe gefunden Max Riemelt. Max Riemelt spielt mit. Max Riemelt am Start. Mit einer Sprechrolle. Ja, mit einer Ballerrolle, einfach viel Action auch. Hat viel Action, spielt Graunhoff schlecht, aber ist dabei. Und er geht jetzt nicht unter. Nein, es gibt genug andere schlechte Performances, die ihn glänzen lassen. Ja, lustigerweise hat er eine Szene im Aufzug mit Ken Reeves, und er spielt Ken Reeves an die Wand. Was nicht so schwierig war, weil Keanu Reeves so eine Hülle ist, die barely existiert. Es ist ein bisschen so wie diese Körpertauschfilme, wo man, wenn ich plötzlich jetzt im Körper von Keanu Reeves stecke, aber an diesem Tag drehen wir Matrix 4 und dann hier spielt man, das ist Max Riemelt, Keanu, are you ready? Und ich so, ja. Und dann stehe ich mit Max Riemelt im Aufzug, mit Kameras auf mir, und so spielt Keanu Reeves ein bisschen. Als wäre gerade jemand anderes in ihm drin. Und ja, aber keine Ahnung, es war weird, aber ja. Ich glaube wirklich, wenn man da nicht so pedantisch und die machen die Reihe kaputt, sondern einfach mal sich darauf einlässt, weil das ist ja auch immer so das Ding so. Die Musik hat mir auch sehr gefallen. Man will ja immer irgendwas wie was sein, aber einfach mal sagt, nein, ich gehe ins Kino, um die Vision der Autorin zu sehen. Das ist mein Ziel und die kann mir immer noch nicht gefallen. Aber wenn ich nicht reingehe mit, ja, das muss so sein und so und warum haben sie nicht, sondern ich gucke mir ein, was war ihre Idee und sie hatte definitiv eine Idee und auch eine, die vielleicht nicht jeder haben würde, die auch nicht jeder in Worte fassen könnte danach. Aber ich meine nur, ich habe, wie geil einfach mal wieder eine Vision zu sehen, das meine ich glaube ich mal im Anfangsmonolog, wie geil mal wieder ins Kino zu gehen, das ist einfach eine Vision. Das ist doch geiler, als diese kackbreit gewaschenen Dinge zu gucken. Und so, du gehst in Matrix 4 und du siehst einfach ihre Vision. Und du denkst halt, du hast die ganze Zeit What the Fuck auf der Stirn stehen, aber ist ja scheißegal. Es ist halt auch die Frage, wenn man so sagt, mit dieser ganzen Erpressungssituation, Warner Brothers so, du machst das jetzt, ob du willst oder nicht, ob sie nicht auch sagt, ich mache jetzt absichtlich einen dummen Film.
Also, weil der war ja auch ein ziemlicher Flop,
der hat ja keine guten Zahlen gespielt.
Was Warner Brothers ja auch bescheuert
ist, irgendwie zu sagen, ah, wir haben ein super erfolgreiches
Franchise, wir machen einen, wir zwingen die
Autorinnen und dann, oh,
großer Flop, so, also vielleicht
war das ja ihr Masterplan,
einen Film zu machen, der gerade die Erwartungen,
also man kann ja viel theoretisieren, wir werden
das vielleicht irgendwann rausfinden, wenn du
irgendwann auf einer Grillparty sie triffst
Und die Dachstattung War das ja ihr Masterplan, einen Film zu machen, der gerade die Erwartungen ... Also, man kann ja viel theoretisieren, wir werden das vielleicht irgendwann rausfinden,
wenn du irgendwann auf einer Grillparty sie triffst und ihr das alles besprechen könnt.
Oder sie in den Podcast kommt.
Wir können ja mal einen Laden, aber kauf es hier aus allen.
Mega gerne.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich fahr nicht, warum es ein Plopp ist, weil alle meiner Meinung nach aus dem Kino gehen sollten und sagen sollten, schau dich jetzt einen Film an, das ist ja crazy.
Und ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, im Sinne von, du hast sowas noch nicht gesehen.
Das war die Erinnerung der Welt. die noch aus dem Kino gehen sollten und sagen sollten, schau dich diesen Film an, das ist ja crazy. Und ja, ich weiß nicht. Ja, im Sinne von, du hast sowas noch nicht gesehen. Was nicht heißt, dass es du sehen willst. Aber auch interessant von Warner Brothers, dass Warner Brothers gesagt hat, ja klar, kann das die Geschichte sein. Wir dürfen namentlich erwähnt werden, als die Leute, die dich erpressen, einen Film zu machen, das Spiel, aber es ist ja nur ein Spiel.
Und diese Transferlastung hat mein Kopf nicht hinbekommen die ganze Zeit, weil in dem Film läuft die ganze Zeit Matrix. Man guckt einen Film, in dem die ganze Zeit irgendwo Matrix läuft, aber die reden die ganze Zeit über das Spiel. Ja. Und ich hab die ganze Zeit wieder ...
Ich bin immer zurückgefallen in ...
Die Filme existieren in dem Film, weil die ja da laufen.
Und das legt einem so Stein in den Weg, dass es die ganze Zeit um dieses Videospiel geht. Ja, vor allem, der Chef von Anderson war ja dann Agent Smith. Und die Firma heisst ja auch, glaube ich, Smith Corporation, die Videospielfirma oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Richtung. Wie heißt die nicht so Simultantec, Simultec? Das kann auch sein, aber ja. Sein Kaffee hieß irgendwie auch Simulation, Simulatte. Ja, das ist das ganze Simulatte. Ist auch so schlecht. Es ist wirklich schlecht. Simulatte hieß sein Kaffee, wo er sein Latte Macchiato getrunken hat. Hieß Simulatte. Was ja wie der Humor der Maschinen ist, die ja diese Matrix programmiert haben, die gesagt haben, weißt du was, steck den Anderson mal in die Matrix, wo wir den Simulatte machen. Fuck it, wir nennen das so. Dann wacht er irgendwann auf und denkt auch so, dass mir das nie aufgefallen ist. Und dass der mein Chef Smith hieß und der war Agent Smith. Wobei die Frage ist, hat er nicht das Spiel so programmiert, dass er Smith heisst, weil er seinen Chef nicht mag oder was? Also kann man ja auch andersrum sehen. Also ganz merkwürdig. Hochgradig merkwürdig. Schickt gerne mal eure Theorien, wie ihr Sinn diesem Film gebt, weil er selbst tut es nicht. Ihr müsst es tun, ihr müsst auch mal selber als williger und aufgeklärter Zuschauer dem Ganzen einen Sinn geben. Tut das gerne mal, schickt uns eure Interpretationen oder was wir falsch verstanden haben. Die neuen Pillen gefallen mir gut. Das neue Design der Pillen. Ne? Die waren nämlich, früher sahen die nicht so aus, früher sahen die hässlich aus. Meine, waren auch keine Pillen, sondern so Tabletten. Doch, das waren schon Pillen. Ehrlich. Das waren schon Pillen, glaube ich. Aber ja, und natürlich diese ganze Action-Ebene mit diesen ganzen verschiedenen Figuren, mit dieser Gang, die dann kämpfen gegen Leute, checkt kein Mensch. Nee, früher waren es so Drops, so Lutschdrops. Ach, aber was ist da der Unterschied? Du meinst, weil die durchsichtigen diese ... Es sind jetzt Kapseln. Es sind jetzt Kapseln. Ach so, mhm. Früher waren es alles klar. Poste das gerne in den Vergleich, dass dir das gut gefällt. Das ist, glaube ich, auch so das riedeste Kompliment, dass wenn du
irgendwann mal Lana verkaufst, hier auf dem
Balkon triffst, sagt, ey, der neue Matrix-Film,
das Design der neuen Pillen
hat mir richtig gut gefallen.
Das ist auch so ein Kompliment, wenn man sagt,
okay, das nimmst du mit aus dem Film.
Was hat dir noch gefallen?
Simulate. Simulate.
Richtig gut.
Ja, das war unsere Rubrik. Wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-ding-e Ja. Also, glaubst du, du bist ein guter Action? Nein. Der sagt jetzt mit dem Wurststern. Ich weiss ja nicht mehr genau, wie die beschrieben sind, solche Action-Szenen. Wahrscheinlich They Fight, und dann kommt irgendein Choreografie-Typ, der sich Sachen ausdenkt. Es sei denn, es ist irgendwie so Kill Bill, wo es wirklich geschichtsträchtige Kämpfe sind. Ja, er fällt mir ein, eine Kollegin wollte mir immer noch das Drehbuch von John Wick mal schicken, aber nicht das, wie es jetzt ist, sondern zum Dreh, weil sie da irgendwie den Kameramann kannte oder so was, und dann soll die mir mal ... Weil das interessiert mich, weil es ja wirklich New Action, da werden vier Sätze gewechselt in diesem Film, wie das geschrieben ist. Wahrscheinlich einfach sehr ausführlich und genauso, wie es am Ende zu sehen ist. Und da frage ich mich aber auch ... Er schlägt mit seiner rechten Faust ...
Mit seiner flachen Innenseite.
... auf das linke Ohr von der Innenseite, wodurch der Kopf zur Seite schnellt.
Aber Obacht, vorher hat Aiden Smith eine leichte Linksbewegung gemacht, weshalb die Hand eher in Richtung Nase als Richtung Wange ging.
Und dadurch seinen Kopf katapultiert gegen die Wand, die Fliesen brechen auf, Blut spritzt herum. Ja. Cut to. Blumenwiese. Cut to Simulatte, Interior Simulatte, Nacht. Ja, schaut den Film an oder auch nicht. Je nachdem, worauf ihr Lust habt, was ihr machen möchtet. Geht mal danach oder davor in Annett. Und dann möchte ich mal wissen, wozu ihr mehr Fragen habt. Geh du noch mal jetzt in Annett. Machen wir gleich die Antenne Annett. Filme, die Fragen aufwerfen. Filme, die wirklich einfach eine Menge Fragen aufwerfen. Das ist eigentlich deine Hausaufgabe, dass du noch bis nächste Woche mal den Film Annett schaust. Ja, aber ich gehe nicht ins Kino. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Kino. Wo hast du denn Matrix geschaut?
Hm?
Wo hast du denn Matrix geschaut?
Ja, ähm, ja.
Also, ähm, verschiedene Streaming-Anbiete. Du kannst Annette auf Prime Video gucken.
Ja, das mach ich. Aber ich hab, das war eine meiner Vorsätze für 22, keine Kinos mehr.
Mein, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Gelaber, auf Laute, Vollidioten, auf Handy klingeln, Handybildschirme.
Mach ich einfach nicht mehr.
Tut mir leid, tut mir leid, dafür kaufe ich immer noch gerne Popcorn, wenn ich vorbeikomme an einem Kino, hole ich mir eine Tüte Popcorn, da machen die ihr am meisten Verdienste mit, ja, ja, ja, von daher ich unterstütze die Kinoindustrie weiter, ich finde das ein gutes Konzept, solange aber nur Vollidioten da reingehen, mache ich nicht mehr mit. Okay, dann gewinnen die Vollidioten, ist ja klar, aber gut. Du überlässt einfach jetzt die Kinos den Vollidioten. So kann man es sehen. Und dann ist es eine Niederlage, die ich eben einstecken muss. Nee, die wir einstecken müssen als die letzten sane Menschen, die noch hingehen. Aber okay, mach du dir, lege du deinen ... Irgendwann, ich spare jetzt mein ganzes Geld, das ich spare, weil ich nicht ins Kino gehe, steckt das alles im Sack. Und wenn ich irgendwie 70 bin, dann baue ich selber ein Kino, wo ich höchstpersönlich mit einer Supersoaker vorne an der Leinwand stehe und jeder, der redet, der wird einmal ins Gesicht gespritzt. Mir ist schon klar, dass das dazu führt, dass alle Leute da hingehen, um zu reden, um ins Gesicht gespritzt zu werden. Solange ich in so eine scheiß plappernde Fresse im Waldwasser spritzen kann, bin ich zufrieden. Nee, oder einfach so Fallstühle, also so Stühle, so Sitze, die merken, die Dezibel merken und du musst leise sein, weil sonst geht, fällt es so runter und guckst Matrix 4. Genau, im Strafsaal, da ist der Strafsaal, minus eins heißt der auch. Ja, und dann kommen so Armgurte, die dich festzurüften. Und diese Clockwork-Orange-mässigen Augenaufhalter.
Und du musst Matrix vier.
Und dann, immer wenn unten dieser Sitz aufgeht,
hörst du auch Schreie aus Kino Minus eins, weil alle da sitzen.
Nein, das gibt keinen Sinn.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Aber genau so ein Kino mache ich auf, mit einem Saal und mir als wütendem 70-Jährigen, der in so einem Schaukelstuhl, einem quietschenden Schaukelstuhl vorne sitzt und alle Leute anspritzt, die reden. Wenn die ganze Zeit auch so wahrscheinlich so wahnsinnig Monolog hält und lauter ist als der Film. Also viele Sachen werden da merkwürdig und du wirst dann an einem Herzinfarkt sterben, weil du so sauer bist auf diese Jugendlichen, die da in Reihe zwei sitzen. So kann ich vielleicht die Welt verändern, bis dahin tut mir einen Gefallen und seid leise.
Geht ins Kino und schaut euch den online an.
Schaut euch Annette und Matrix Resurrections in einer Reihenfolge eurer Wahl an. Bis dahin.
Aber das ist unser Double Feature-Tipp. Bis dahin, viel Spaß.
Haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, wir heben ab!